as I predicted this gang of six bill is
a complete and utter joke earlier in the
week the president empowered
congressional leaders to come up with a
bipartisan deal to address the status of
those eight hundred thousand or so
dreamers that Obama through executive
action protected from deportation
remember there were some prerequisites
build the wall add more border agents
and immigration judges and end chain
migration and the Visa Lottery
but today senators dick Durbin Lindsey
Graham and Jeff Flake unveiled their
great compromise the moment I heard it
was those three involved I knew it was
gonna be bad by the way if you're
wondering why the president has already
in the words of dick Durbin personally
rejected the bill I'll tell you why it
would increase chain migration violating
one of the president's non-negotiables
number one the daca recipients gets
citizenship and can then sponsor
relatives and their parents for
renewable three-year periods the money
for border enforcement is as I predicted
a pittance 2.3 billion is all Durbin
Graham and flake offered and by the way
only 1.6 billion will go toward the
construction of the wall or the double
fencing and what are they supposed to
build the wall with styrofoam for that
much money
a real border wall is expected to cost
about 20 billion dollars and while
Congress anguishes to find the money
well by the way remember we're going to
rebuild Puerto Rico for about 50 billion
and illegals cost us all in about a
hundred and thirteen billion dollars a
year so do not tell me we don't have the
money to enforce our own border the
bipartisan proposal placed new
constraints on the Department of
Homeland Security that will hamper the
actual building of the wall and this
really torches me the Visa Lottery would
simply be transferred to temporary
protective status
meaning those visas would result in even
more lower skilled immigrants coming
into the country the bar is even lower
for that group so I suggest that the
great bipartisan working group sharpen
their pencils and return to the table
this will not do no way nohow
again it would increase chain migration
it would lead to more immigration and it
would spike the number of low-skilled
immigrants this is a bill the president
should love right oh the President of
Mexico that is Republicans should run
not walk away from it just like in
2006-2007 2013 and 2014 open borders the
open borders bipartisan cartel tries to
trick the American people every time
well guess what we're not Charlie Brown
and you're not Lucy but Donald Trump is
not going to be led down this garden
path on this one no way during the
presidential election Lindsey Graham got
1% of the vote in his home state of
South Carolina during the primaries yes
1% and Jeff Flake himself is so
unpopular in Arizona he was forced to
retire rather than face the electorate
let's face it the immigration views of
flake and Graham are not popular and the
president should not tie his bright
political future to these walking anvils
they're just gonna sink him right down
for a real perspective on immigration
the president should listen to the
voices of the silent majority that I
heard loud and clear once again on my
radio show today these days you don't
find one African American on the
worksite in any Atlanta subdivision it's
a shame it's all Hispanic it's all
illegal their equity price again is
built on illegal labor there are
plenitude of a leg of labor holding
wages down for the Americans by the guys
think tit well why don't you guys get
off the corner Chicago or Chicago is
such a carnage Florida's crime and all
this uh gun violence but there's so many
illegals in Chicago right now
so chart is so hard for anyone to get a
job the people know how high the stakes
are right now and they're already living
with the results of open borders
policies by the way that were supported
by the same politicians pushing this bad
deal on Trump America my friends is
being and has been completely
transformed culturally economically and
electoral by illegal and chain migration
and by the way ms-13 is still
proliferating this is precisely what
Americans rejected in the last
presidential election it's one of the
major reasons
Trump won nobody wants America to be the
next hole holding and recalls or holes I
guess we decided to believe that if what
Graham and flake are pushing is so
popular then and it's so right it's so
common sense
what are they also afraid to come on
this show and defend their proposal we
we get no callbacks from any of them I
wonder why and that's the angle